[Music]
okay hi everyone we are working on a
design review of question function
functionality
so
let's uh
see where we're at
where should i start
well if your cvs is updated we can start
um with any of the symbols listed there
this is a continuation of a meeting from
a couple weeks ago
where we
dove in deep on question interface and i
think we have some decent direction
there
okay
so
it'd be productive to look at the 13
version 13 updates on the other symbols
okay should i be running something in a
prototype build or something uh if you
have a 13 from the last week had branch
build that's that's good okay
should i be opening this notebook in
that
um
which notebook are your first notebook
yeah if you want to run if you want to
run the
the demos that we have in there then yes
oh yeah you don't need to
yeah i mean yeah it's calling notebook
button there so it'll open up in the
same
session
okay
all right let me see let me
yep am i up to date here
okay let's go
open docker tools okay where should i
start
um
we could start with a question object
okay
which for people in the live stream who
don't know this has been around
since since 12 30 in the last version
but it was it was kind of an early
version there and it's going to be
filled out to become a more
useful interesting
okay tool good
so what should we look at here
um
so
let's see you seem unprepared
what are we really trying to achieve in
this meeting
we're yeah so i design review for in
general updates for this whole
system in 13 which it has significant
amount of updates coming to it so we
want to look at the whole story let's
take it from the top
well from the top of the story is the q
a form notebook
yeah work right is is the main thing
from the top okay but so now are we not
looking at that here is that correct
this is the language level interface to
all of that is that correct right if we
want yes yes so everything that empowers
that notebook
is programmatically available
this way
so this submit
in this case is an in-notebook
thing is that correct that's right
that's right the answer key is in there
people who are clever enough to do
an input form or whatever can see the
answer key
that's glitchy
just that the background is white yeah
the whole thing is going to be white
yeah okay
surely that should left justify though
uh structures that the way it is in the
design that you're implementing
uh i think it's currently not like that
in the design but i'll double check
okay
all right so what are we reviewing here
um
so i mean we talked some about these
names last time for the question
interfaces i don't think we need to dive
into those again today
i guess that's that's so you've got did
you get renaming done or not
um no we didn't which most of this team
has been on pto most of the time since
do we actually need this meeting guys
yeah i think it'd be good to look at
the the changes outside of the question
interface so yeah i thought there was
more updated in this notebook but i
guess i guess there's not the main thing
is that
question object that note about question
object except in question interfaces
um as the first argument is kind of the
i know but we discussed that last time
didn't we
yes okay so let's go let's go on to the
next phase let's go on to
um
let's see what should we look at next
sylvia do you have is there a good
direction to go here
i feel like assessment function
okay so that's what's updated there
okay
i i feel like you guys don't need this
meeting which is good
it is left justified in the design by
the way so
okay so that's a mistake okay
okay what should we be looking at here
right so there's uh
this new
this that new usage there is uh
sort of a
weird design that we came up with so an
assessment function can have the answer
key just built inline to it but it can
also be deployed to the cloud and backed
by cloud objects so that the you know
the student yep
so then it's a then it's a cloud object
but a cloud object in addition to just
having a single
assessment function deployed to it can
have an entire quiz deployed to it in
which case each question has a unique id
and you can send an answer to that
question object for assessment
for a specific
question what is if i did a get on that
cold quiz cloud object what would i get
back it's implemented as an external
bundle so you get a directory
something that represents i don't know
if it's it wouldn't give you a zip file
give you some abstraction of a directory
oh god
right it does what it's implemented
using external bundle
wow
so
using an expression
then we could have something where that
id is somehow indexing into the
association of for expression or
something
but this is a really that's a wild
animal there
right
right but i mean we're
yeah yeah so for people who really want
to dive into low-level things it's kind
of annoying but we're building
high-level utilities for doing
the sort of stuff you can
use the assessment function
here with the list is the first object
where it's a cloud object and an id to
refer to
the
deployed you know the index within the
deployed assessment function
right so if you want to give an answer
to that specific question
that's the way you would reference it
yeah i understand okay
this list of object ids seems like a
fine way to do it
it's no it's kind of horrifying but i
don't know what else we would do and i
think that's a i mean how would you
deploy
the
whole quiz collection of assessment
objects
using question to play well i mean you
really you would do it from within the
notebook the q a formula book there's
you know in the settings menu you say
deploy and then you hit generate and it
does it i don't think it's great but i
don't have a better alternative yeah
okay
i see on our live stream is asking will
style sheets include question object
styles
that are specific styles for questions
treasure do you have an answer for that
it's a reasonable question i'd certainly
something that can you repeat the
question
will our style sheets
um include styles specific to question
objects
i mean it's a good question currently
they don't
so
but they probably should
has has design even looked at i mean
this doesn't look very good right we
have an updated spec from design that's
sure we did implementation on okay what
is that updated spec is that is that
cell then
some other random kind of cell and it
just has an enclosed thing that has
styles yeah i'm gonna post the link
if you want to yeah
i think you guys are not well prepared
today you guys are often quite well
prepared but today
that's that's probably that's probably
true it usually helps brady's here but
he's busy on a different meeting and
sylvia and schroeder were out most of
last week so i think i think that's
you're not off base there
good
right so it's it's going to be these
white with the border instead of just
gray
the left column is in it sounds okay and
then i can imagine something where you
might want different styles and is there
any way to do that like with a style
sheet what is this picking up even do
you know
is it picking up styles from a style
sheet or what
well currently no it's just using
like
baked in stuff and default styles of the
controls right so that's something we
should think about
right we can put it all into a template
box that's defined in the global style
sheet
sounds right to me
okay
let's look at some more here what else
is there to look at here um
so i mean you were asking like how would
this get deployed outside of the
notebook oh so we've talked about cloud
service deploy as a potential thing but
that doesn't exist yet
so we're creating a resource function do
you care to look at the design of a
resource function
well i mean
cloud service deploy
okay
explain here
i mean i don't understand
does this design exist here i mean if i
run this yes yes that's a
resource function definition notebook
um
right so this is base under the hood
it's doing cloud deploy of an external
bundle that has a bunch of different
endpoints for interacting with the
deployed assessment functions and
question objects in different ways
what the heck is this
oh boy i don't understand this little
one
right so if you have a question object
with this i mean this is horrifying what
this is doing okay go ahead what do you
say right so
with the answer key when the astro key
is in line you need a way to
deploy the assessment function to cloud
but then you also need you need to get
back two things you need to get back
that cloud object that you deployed to
and you need to get back a version of
the question object that where the
answer key is replaced with the
deployment
that's that this function does that
okay
look why don't you return an association
here that's a precursor of cloud service
deploy what it will do
that's exactly what it's doing
i don't see an association first look at
the first example
yeah but this isn't an association what
is that sylvia if it's only an
a single assessment function not within
a question object
it's not right it should return
something with the same structure always
okay
because those ones are
are very specific and strange because
you couldn't really do that within a
form notebook in that style
okay look
look
just keep it consistent yeah maybe we
don't even want to document deploying an
assessment function directly because
it's kind of kind of weird yeah
okay
but so
where can you use this cloud deployed
thing yeah
anywhere i mean the cl the question
object you get back you could
put that into a q a form notebook or you
could use anywhere you want right and
it's a cloud object
if i take that
and evaluate it
i'm so confused here
so isn't it
right
so the idea for the one above where it's
the full question object that
question object has
the cloud object replacing
why is it an image that assessment
function why is it an image
oh because the the
function resource tools
do that for dynamic content because it
shows up well when you deploy it
yeah
so
this question deploy produces a cloud
object which if i refer to it somewhere
else
it will then indirectly pull it in so in
a question object it will be able to
pull it in here
correct right you want the cloud object
that you get back is primarily for like
administration if you want to change
your permissions if you want to delete
it
right that that's why you would use
cloud object yes the question object is
what you actually want to take out of it
for the
primary purpose
of right creating quizzes
okay
okay what do you want me to look at here
i mean so that design needs to be more
consistent and i think we understand
that yeah the the direct you sign
assessment function we'll we'll fix that
okay yeah can we look at the the index
notebook
this is more of like
if you deployed it through
the form notebook
this is what you would get back instead
of the assistant
the next one down where it says workflow
demo is that what you're saying yeah i
don't know why it's labeled workflow
demo that doesn't make any that's
so
so when you create the external bundle
there will be
an index.nb file in that bundle
that
this is
basically the content
of index.nbc of index.nb and we can we
will send this to design and get it
printed up but just just the content
if you have god this is confusing
um
i don't understand i don't understand
this so when you click generate in the
authoring part of a form notebook
instead of it just
making so in the q a form notebook
instead of just making an authoring
notebook it gives you back this
if
cloud deploy was selected right
because the reason that we made this is
because
it's it's not clear what to do
when you click generate and it just
gives you back a notebook it makes a lot
more sense if you get back a little
index that says okay here's where the
quiz is located you can share this url
this is where the results are located
this is where you can modify
permissions etc
okay
well i think you should call the top one
deployed quiz notebook or something like
that
deployed quiz yep
right we haven't used the word quiz a
lot of places but it seems like the
obvious thing to call this
well let's not because people might use
it for the other person right we we
spent five minutes trying to come up
with a
more
generic term that still
told people what it was and i don't
think we
came up with anything better i would
just call it deployed notebook
and the the heading at the top is
certainly not demo quiz it's presumably
some name
yeah that is that that's as an example
you know it could be in curly brackets
here that's just
the name the actual name that we put in
in the authoring notebook settings
of what to call it and that's a self
link
to so this notebook that you're looking
at would also be a cloud deployed
notebook
and that that would link to the cloud
deployment that's why it's blue
because it's a link
okay
but i would just say deployed notebook
to get around the question whether it's
called the quiz or not
okay what does results mean
so if you're the the teacher
to use a specific term how you get back
the results of the students that have
taken it so far
okay so we're going to create another
resource function for importing a data
set
so you should say something like
uh
collector for submitted results or
something
and you can also add a you know a
sentence of text if you want to
yeah
right like we did on the next one we
should have a
caption for that one yep agreed
um
okay
all right let's see
uh
okay anything else on this
um yeah and we have the start of a guide
page there at the bottom
if if it seems reasonable i can get that
into cvs right away this one here yes
we don't have a dedicated guide page for
this stuff yet and 12 we kind of put it
onto it another guide page where it's
not particularly useful so we should
have a dedicated one
those are weird i mean well okay fine i
mean i understand the
uh
okay sure i mean it's a decent start
um
okay okay what's the blur does the blur
the top seem reasonable should i leave
that in correlations or should we
oh boy
i know you usually like to write those
or rewrite no i i usually don't want i i
actually prefer not to write if
like is the wrong there's a wrong verb
i i know you usually write this
i usually end up like this what do we
want to say
what we want to say so first of all
um
let's see this should probably have a
heading like uh
setting up questions and assessments
something like that
yep
sure
otherwise it's it's like who's asking a
question of who of what whichever
um
no i mean you want to say something like
uh
where's the course tools i mean there's
no course here this could be a survey
for all anybody knows
right i'm saying right it's definitely
more engineering for defining
uh
questions
whose answers can be submitted to a
central
uh
who's to defining questions
um
that can be assessed or graded either
locally or in the cloud or something
you can say the questions can
involve
a
variety of interfaces from multiple
choice to
geographic locators or something
um
in addition there's fully automated
assessment
including i don't know what feature you
want to bring out of assessment
uh
there's both a i mean you want to say
something like there's both a language
level
way of setting up questions and
assessments
as well as
a
you know as well as q a form notebooks
which provide a
notebook based authoring environment or
something
right
ethan is asking has this has any dog
eaten this food
um
so
yeah dogs that eat similar food have
been involved in the process for still
very early we haven't really
put this out for
real world testing yet
but yeah
we definitely have
people in house who are how's the wolf
from you team users who are dogs
um they haven't used it but we've met
with them and we've
told them our plans and they've
you know we've edited things based on
their comments
that it's definitely the goal for them
to use it because what they're using for
quizzes now has okay craig on our live
stream
notes that he's a professor and that's
why he's watching this and he wants to
see if he can use it in a class that
would be wonderful
right um
and uh yeah i mean look
there's there's a
this is i think connected to a whole
bunch of things that have been done in
various university systems and so on
including some projects that have been
done for universities and so on so i i
this is not but i the you know the
problem is the dog ain't gonna happily
eat its food until the food is well
prepared
and it's no good providing uh
you know poorly cooked dog food
and i think when do we feel this dog
food is going to be properly cooked 13.
okay so in a few months yes
okay fine
right i mean
if people on the chat are our professors
and they happen to be in the beta
program i would certainly love to
connect with them
right
and i think i mean the problem is
there's one of these things which can't
really it can't really be tested until
it's all there and by the time it's all
there it might as well be released on an
experimental basis
right which is i think what we're
planning to do
right
uh
i think it'd be interesting to to i mean
you know
i don't even know
like what will be involved in making the
eiwl
exercises use this
is that plausible or is that not
plausible
i think so i mean one of the
um
comparison methods that we will have an
assessment function is code which will
hook into the code equivalents
right
um so that's a that's a privatization of
the code equivalence functionality that
we used for eil
the question is what custom
transformation rules have people put in
there and transferring yeah making sure
whatever
yeah uh
whatever
yeah special
rules have been added for eiwl
would need to be done it wouldn't just
be who's this global set of rules
um
at one point rick was i don't know who's
who is like so who's pm english
this or eiwl
no i'm talking about the the using of
code of the code comparison tool
in the assessment function here
oh i assume addison edison
can tell me if he's not trying to make
that
um yeah
uh and uh with help with brady also
yeah okay
what else do we need to look at here
um i think i think that's good i think
we
okay so so the q a notebook
can i
launch that here
it's not in file new do you have that
snippet of code oh no it's not merged
that branch isn't merged yet is it
shorter no it's not
so okay i just want to go through this
workflow again okay okay can you send me
something that will launch that or can
you is there a easy way to get to it
um
shorter is there
uh
it would probably take me a minute
okay but i just want to walk through
this workflow so the basic workflow is
you go to file new
and what are we calling it
q a formula
okay
file new q a form notebook in that
notebook you put a bunch of questions
right
where do you put the where do you author
the assessment stuff
is that also in that notebook yes yes
yes and for simple assessments like
multiple choice well it'll be templated
and
all guilified for
complex things where you're specifying
custom tolerance measurements you'll
have to write some code
like if you if i think that maybe the
easiest thing is to just go to that
design that we had
earlier
you can see
the one that i posted in the zoom chat
okay
oh no no but i don't want to design i
want to see the actual running thing
right okay
yeah i'm really not that interested in
this
i mean this is
right the other the other side has like
the authoring like what it looks like in
the notebook right yeah to the right
i just want to zoom out a lot
okay
but that's a generated notebook yeah
okay let's walk through again there you
go this is okay
so what we're doing is we're bringing up
the q a form notebook why is that one
word it shouldn't be
right
you understand that right that shouldn't
be one word smooshed together it should
have a space right
do you understand or not yep yes okay
good
there
um
okay
so we go here i mean is this the actual
version that's running now or is this
some old design that we shouldn't bother
to look at this is a new design that i'm
currently implementing
okay
okay
so
question prompt assessment function okay
so the question prompt is
what is two plus two
right
and and this is what you get how did you
get this that came from insert
yeah insert multiple choice right
that's not multiple choices
uh
no that's a multiple choice
i mean we maybe the the
tag assessment function should be
changed too absolutely
it's something like choices the question
i mean i think
what is this look
why don't you say
edit
this multiple choice question
right do you have names for all the all
the question types
yes that's what we talked about last
time that okay fine so then you should
have a human name for the question type
you should say edit this blah blah blah
question
right
does that make sense yes
okay then question prompt seems fine
and then here
it's
um
what is this choices
okay in this case it will be choices but
you need to write something custom for
each type of question then right right
when we already have names for these
things
but that's not the assessment function
but that's not telling you which one is
correct right well there's the radio
buttons there for that you would select
the radio button of the
one that's correct
okay then you should should be
communicated something choices yeah it's
hopeless that it isn't
choices paren
select correct answer
or something probably the top one should
be pre-selected
yeah right no
no it shouldn't be pre-selected because
if you pre-select it right then every
time people will fill this out
and
i mean if you say if the confirmed thing
is hit and nothing has been selected
right then it should complain because
then there's no answer that's right you
can't win the student can't win there's
no correct answer
okay we can rely on the confirm button
yeah right but i mean what you need to
do here is
is
somehow you've got to indicate they've
got to fill out both the choices
and which one is correct
so you might want i don't know what the
other interfaces look like but you might
say
correct question mark as a heading for
that column there
i mean this is useless assessment
function is useless what you want to do
is label these two columns
correct question mark and this would be
labeled when you switch to when you
switch to code then like the tag would
be well that's fine that's not what
we're doing here this is the three
version right
yep so you need a heading and then you
need to indicate those two columns
separately
question from the live stream how do you
include multimedia content to your
question prompt
you would have to do that in the code
thing like the template mode is just for
doing easy stuff because
well the reason is because input fields
don't support you just putting actually
maybe they do they do yeah they do
well theoretically there's no reason you
can't then
we don't want people to have to put
string characters around strings so yeah
no
yeah so in that case
i'm sorry what
look guys because i have a solution the
problem i think the prompt should be a
string input field not necessarily no i
don't think so i think because prompt
should be a piece of it you shouldn't
have to type string characters around of
course not it should be a piece of a
notebook like other form notebook
elements
and it shouldn't be some kind of
impoverished string
okay there's no reason it can't be a
piece of a notebook right which can have
any content you want in it
are they making sense but then strings
have to have string characters right
what are you talking about you have to
put stuff
on the string you're typing a piece of a
notebook you're typing a cell in there
okay i just don't understand that maybe
sure yeah no no no i'm not sure no
forget the fact that this is a that this
is input fields okay
in a form notebook you can have a piece
of a form notebook that isn't is
a cell in a notebook the cell can
contain anything how it's packaged in
order to be you know wrapped up in the
internal code is a different question it
might be in box data it might have all
kinds of string characters that's a
different question
i don't see any reason to impoverish
this as being a string it just seems
stupid well i think most people probably
want their prompts to be a string and if
they want to do something
interesting like multimedia they can
just use the code version and then it's
just all in a cell so
well okay but i i don't think that needs
to be that way i mean this can be just
like a text cell
so they can enter an inline cell here
and all that kind of thing why isn't
this just a text cell
it could be why is it a string why isn't
it a text cell
i would it if it works like a text cell
that makes sense
okay if it's a text cell i think we're
good but then don't try and stuff it
into an input field there
similarly here i mean there should be
pictures you could put in pictures here
and so on as well right i don't i
wouldn't know how to implement that as a
text oh hey
that's a different issue yeah i have to
talk to you
okay
so anyway so what happens here is
you create so the question types are in
the insert which i can't see right now
did you manage to get me a version that
i can actually use
uh
there's not an easy way you could do it
right now
okay fine all right so this insert
has a bunch of question types right
right is that correct that's right okay
so then i'm i'm entering a question it's
by default in template mode
and um
i really don't know why this isn't
called gui
template is really confusing to me
everybody knows what gui means
if everybody knows what gui means it
should be called guili
i think so
i think it's less confusing than
template
okay i mean do do most teachers who use
mathematica know what gui means
probably
they're certainly not going to
understand template because i don't even
understand template
i
i think if the ones that have it uh have
this mode if it opens into that mode by
default it doesn't matter too much what
we call it and yeah gooey's fine
okay
somebody's going to say what's that
strange gui animal exactly
that's fine is it like new is it like
right
i really like using
yeah
okay all right so the first step is
you're entering questions here what does
tools have in it
just random stuff for for
adorning questions in various ways
correct
annotations and
yeah
boxes all right check does checking
generate what does generate produce that
produces that
the index
right if you're cloud deploying it which
you should no no wait a minute what does
generate have in it what does it do can
it produce it can it do it locally is
this the look
so there's that gear menu to the left of
those that where you can choose whether
it's going to be cloud deployed or not
yeah
right okay but generate does something
by default
when it does something just submit do
something by default here
well it's a user note but that's the
quiz or user i understand it but does so
submit does the a definite thing but it
assesses yeah it does the assessment
okay right so here that gear menu
specifies what generate should do
right
okay and the default is what
it's not something we put thought into
what do you mean what do you mean well
what are the possibilities it's either
so there's
it can either the assessment can either
live in the cloud or live in the
notebook and then you can either decide
to have all the questions in the user
notebook
okay let me point something out okay
given that you don't know what the
default should be and i don't think it's
obvious what the default should be don't
make generate just do some random thing
set by you know it's kind of like
i think
i think the default should be i think
the default should be assessment in the
notebook all at once
right so well so fine but i think what
you should do with generate is produce
some dialogue or some menu of what the
possibilities are with one of them
selected
okay are making sense don't don't have
something where you have to indirectly
decide what to do and then press the
button here because i don't think i
think the probability you write and what
people want to do might be 30
right but that means you should have
them pick at the time
rather than just get confused you can
track if they've said it and not force
them to do it again surely if they
haven't picked no no
they're going to click twice
it's not going to be enough to click
once
so you can set the default under
generate to be whatever they did the
last time
do you see what i'm
saying yes
okay don't have it automatically do it
because it's not obvious what it will do
make sense
yeah can see the second click being
annoying if you just set it in the
settings menu if you just open the gear
and set everything and then you click
generate have it you don't save it again
think about it think about it this is a
person who is about who's just spent
you know i mean
it's like the published dialogue for
notebooks going to the cloud i don't
have a problem clicking a couple of
times because it's a big thing i just
made my whole notebook i just spent
hours making the notebook
and then um
uh
you know
um
uh
and then i do this it's no big deal that
i have to click twice it's not like i'm
demon clicking this thing to redeploy it
every five seconds
right
okay so you don't have to worry about it
right um
so
okay so then this generates and you're a
little bit muddled what what what it's
actually generating here that seems like
there are five things it could generate
there's there's two main there's two
main configuration choices that you
should make whether it's local or cloud
deployed and whether all the questions
are assessed at once or whether they're
individually assessed
okay
all right okay those are the two main
choices all right okay so then that
generates a thing
that the generate returns to you
something that presumably here in the
gui
is something that is a bit like the
published dialogue is that correct
yes well it's yeah it's bigger
what do you mean it's bigger it's it's
returning to you a pointer to this
notebook that is to be used by students
to submit things together with something
which is where you're going to get the
results from is that correct
i mean
af so after the generate completes what
we're saying is if you did the
deployment you'll get one of those index
dot nb notebooks like they were looking
at before
no no no no look what you've got to get
back is number one a url to send your
students
number two url to go look for the
results that the the things they
submitted is that correct
yeah those are two of the important
things okay
have you designed what you get back by
pressing generate that's what the index
statement notebook is that we were
looking at earlier
it has those things in it okay fine then
i don't think that's the right thing
because i think what you want to do for
that notebook is do things like
much like the publish dialogue with like
qr codes and click to copy and all that
kind of stuff
do you get what i'm saying we had to
click the copy in there we could put a
qr code in but
i'm not sure the qr code makes sense
because that will show
the assessment url as well which is not
what you want
right
no the qr code would just be for example
i know that's the url the point of
having a qr code is so that you can say
i'm now going to publish in some talk
and people can see the qr code right
we could have a separate page we could
have a separate page that's public that
has a qr code that you could show
on the on the you know projector i think
that would be reasonable because that
might be a useful thing here's your test
rather than you know if if everybody's
actually in a physical lecture room if
that ever happens again
they you know it might be that they
actually want to see the qr code
everybody can hold up their phone and
find out where that you know where the
test is another we could have another
endpoint that's just the qr code yeah
possibly yes
um
okay so then
the students
do their homework at some time
and and there's not a lot of time gates
for this is that correct yet
yeah we definitely have
talked about it
and we have ideas about it all right
okay
recording time stamps but really okay so
they they press the button they and they
submit the result
right
i don't know i don't know why they have
a check button there i mean that's the
solution
the check and the question mark are both
not right they shouldn't be there okay
all right fine
okay
then i press submit
the thing shows up in what
so for the student
yeah assuming that thank you for sending
this in
well assuming the assessment is all
automated it marks up right and wrong
answers and gives you okay right there
okay so that's one of the options that
the teacher has is that submit
can
actually grade the thing right then and
there right
okay but either way it sends it in to
the teacher portal right
and what how does it show up there
well we we have some tools built that
we're going to publish a resource
function for retrieving as a data set to
all the
results okay
but what is the default thing if you go
to the url that's specified in that page
that i didn't understand very well at
the beginning um if you go to that url
what do you see
the thing that was on the page was
the
code for the resource function that
retrieves the data set we don't have a
web interface for
reviewing grades
yet okay fine we could add that at some
point but you can also put it in a
database too which would just be
androids in a database that's true
okay
okay
uh let's see
comments from craig here
um
let's see
okay he's commenting on write some code
answer this or write an alpha query
oh
yeah yeah i don't think we've thought
about the world from alpha query case
have we
that's not a um that's a very
interesting case i mean we've thought
about code equivalency i don't think
we've thought about wolfman alpha
equivalency
right we if we have not
that would i mean you could actually run
the the thing but you should run the
positive right right and the plaza pick
up the underlying
structure i mean that's not a and then
do code equivalence on the underlying
structure right
because equivalence of the natural
language is is you know impossible
basically i mean that's that's super
difficult but that's an interesting idea
to have a wolfman alpha
input field as a possible
thing you can
do assessment on it's a good idea
okay um
face commenting be useful to make sure
the question prompt
can use the new tech input method
yes well that's another good reason for
it to be a cell
that's an excellent reason for it to be
a cell people wanting to enter sort of
non-interpretable math
um
marco is commenting templates should
have slots to fill like when you use
autocomplete for functions
i see you you're suggesting that it used
the placeholder things
i don't think that's the the this just
needs a bit of redesign this isn't quite
right it really needs to be much more
cellular so to
speak neither in a neither in a phone
nor a biological sense but a different
sense of cellular
um
right
well if if you remember we talked about
question generator
uh
i don't know maybe a month ago
as a perspective design where that would
that that's our tool for like
parameterized generated questions
what does that have to do with this
is it's
that's how i interpreted what you just
said about slots
you know i think that's a different
thing but that's okay that's
programmatically generating question
function and assessment function objects
right that's no okay i misunderstood
that yeah i think that's a person's
question
right
uh question prompt could have a
suggestions bar
yeah that's somewhat interesting
and it's a piece of ui to just provide
tools right there
that's we should think about that that's
an interesting possibility
um
ethan asks where do you put the student
emails
to send the thing to
so i don't think we are sending
i mean we certainly could and we
certainly could provide a resource
function to send stuff to a list of
students
right i mean yeah we we couldn't create
a tool that just called sendmail that's
that's one line of code um right but boy
this isn't one line of code is
maintaining the class
right right we're not trying to build an
lms so
they're going to be typing in the roster
right
but yeah
what do you mean and what will they
actually do in the actual workflow the
actual workflow they'll get back at url
and then they'll send it to their
students sometimes that's right that's
right and typically they have they have
some ways to post they can post things
to students already right yeah that's a
solved problem for universities across
the board i don't think you need to
resell that we don't need to solve that
problem
um
let's see marcos comments shouldn't
generate the preview and then commit at
the end
to save into the cloud well that has to
do with what generate actually has
underneath it which we don't completely
know at this point
um
having a preview tool that doesn't do
the deployment might make sense
ethan is commenting that if the
assessment is within the notebook sent
to the student then it is hackable
absolutely yes that's the whole point
there are different cases where the
assessment is only in the cloud versus
the assessment of something that can be
locally executed in the notebook now in
the case where it is self-grading
does it
allow it shouldn't allow
you to
i mean it
if even if it's self-grading it should
still have the option to have the
grading happen in the cloud
am i making sense you mean report back
to the cloud no no i mean
that somebody receives a notebook okay
they've got their homework
to do okay
they say they're like oh you know i want
to make my homework look good okay let
me hack open the notebook and just find
all the answers and just type them in
or actually if they're a little bit
better they just have a program that
parses the notebook and reconstitutes a
notebook with all the answers filled in
sure
okay so my point is that that would be
avoided if the actual
uh answering of the questions
was even if it is to be done
in
uh you know even if the student is
showing the answers
after they press submit
that the actual transaction of is this
the right answer would happen on the
server
do you get what i'm saying
i get what you're saying
that
doesn't happen the design of assessment
function as is right now either it says
a function has the answer key in it or
it's a cloud object in it
fine so i'm saying i'm saying
you can put a cloud object into it but
still have the assessment be visible to
the student
you get what i'm saying
let me go through it again yes you were
sent a notebook okay
if the notebook contains the answers
in the code of the notebook
it is
fairly easy for somebody if they wanted
to do it to write a program that
excavates reverses you know excavates
the notebook simply produces
the result of the homework which is
the notebook with all answers extracted
from the notebook itself filled in as
answers that's right okay
okay so to avoid that what we have to do
is make it so that the answers are
simply not in the notebook the only
thing that's in the notebook is a cloud
object right
okay now how do we
prevent the well i see at the very least
then the student if they have the cloud
object right there could check an answer
against the cloud object but so long as
the permissions are set correctly on the
cloud object they cannot get the cloud
object that's right and we also have uh
you know it uses cloud authentication
and we have like a mac submissions
option i don't remember the exact name
where any given student can only submit
so many times
if you could get the cloud object
contents you could do the same thing
that we talked about for the local
notebook
right right but the permissions you know
the external professional has many
endpoints some of them are public or
yeah
however the permissions do have to allow
execute access otherwise the person
can't locally check their work exactly
right but the case where
they
are sort of a blind
uh blind grading so to speak happening
not
visible to the student
that would then have permissions where
they couldn't even execute the cloud
object right right right
right we we invented
new uh
permissions
terms for like a student and teacher i
don't remember what we called them but
okay yeah you can you can set students
to like a permission group and teachers
to a permission group and those people
have the expected
privileges
um
right a is mentioned in a live stream
what about anti-cheat system about
randomization of question order
randomization of numerical answers yes
those are things that the framework we
have will make it rather easy to do
um
but the gui
which we were looking at here is for the
simpler case where you're not doing that
that's what question generators are for
right guys that's right it was
certainly that random numerical value
thing the reordering of groups of
questions isn't something we've really
thought about
this is a good idea
yeah
why
well i
and we have thought about a question
pool which might sort of do that as well
kind of related well if you give every
answer from a question pool
that then it's the same thing right
um
i don't understand i mean you're saying
if you pick random sample from the from
the pool
right if you have a pool with four
questions and you and you
you have choose four of them randomly
then it's the same as obviously that's a
random random sample right
so i guess we do have a solution for
that
um
right
and various comments here about i mean
look we have the capability to do all
kinds of cool
security things here i think we first
have to get our main functionality up
and running and then securing it like
you know throwing answers onto a
blockchain and things like this
are you know nice featurettes
that i think we can layer in later
once we understand that the flow is
working and so on
i mean you know a lot of what we've been
dealing with is things like
different question types
where you can do things like uh you know
pin the tail on the donkey type thing
and do you hit the right place in the
picture those kinds of things
plus of course we have our own a lot of
our own stuff using natural language and
so on
um
okay
let's see philippe comments that uh they
work in edtech that uses quizzes as
their main functionality yeah well
this is our world of um
uh this is the the thing you get by
having this giant technology stack that
we have
is all these little turnkey things
people people really want we end up
building and then we have a very
powerful version of them because they
leverage all of the rest of our
technology stack
um but yeah it's remarkable how
complicated the workflow is for things
like quizzes
um
as we are finding out all right is there
anything else we should make sure to
cover in this meeting
no i think we've covered
what we wanted to
actually we've covered more than you
originally yesterday
like
um
right well looks very nice i mean uh i
look forward to the next iteration when
i can actually run it when is it going
into the main
builds
i think the next duration will be in the
main builds
which will be when
the things to do on that pr or are we
just waiting for some reviewers to sign
off on it i think we're waiting on
reviews right now
and then you'll be able to just run
some code
be good
okay
well sounds good let's wrap it up okay
thanks guys and thanks to folks on the
live stream and i'm glad that they're
people
who are interested in this functionality
we look forward to getting it out very
soon